Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie lots of Spider-Man
Homecoming hype happening right now people
going crazy about getting Carnage into the
new movies.
Some explain what's going on in a general
history for his character in the comics in
on the ultimate Spider-Man TV show is a couple
different versions of him in surprise surprise,
he actually debuted around the time Deadpool
debuted so bunch of people talking about Carnage
being in the new Spider-Man Sony Marvel films
even though it's kind of too late to get them
into Spider-Man Homecoming.
There's a trilogy there's plenty of room for
other versions of the venom symbiote and Carnage.
Just to explain who he is is basically like
a spinoff version of the venom Symbiote.
So if you guys haven't ever seen at there's
actually an ultimate Spider-Man cartoon on
Disney XD where they done a bunch of different
versions of the characters including anti
venom which is like a whole other thing but
it's very different from the comics so what
am in a do some and explain who Carnage is
his story in the comics some of the big storylines
if you really want to reincarnate story because
there actually try to do some really cool
stuff with him in the dark old which gets
into agents of shield.
The stuff is happening on TV now.
So he's a very present in what's happening
with the Spider-Man character in movies and
TV, even if it's a long shot that we would
see him in a movie and I think the big reason
why Lynn Manwell wants to play Carnage in
I think he's referring to the Kletus Kasidy
like the crazy insane version of Carnage from
the comics it just because it is such an interesting
spin on a character that you don't normally
see in big movies like this, so the crazier
actors get to be in movies more fun.
It tends to be for them like a really good
example of that is Tom Hiddleston who plays
Loki really amazing performance that he's
had in the marvel universe.
So far, but when they were originally casting
that first Thor movie.
He went to like his friend Kenneth Branagh
who is directing the movie and asked him about
reading for Thor and he was like no no no
you do want to play Thor you want to play
Loki ill be way more fun for you.
so that is like a whole other story because
there actually is like a screen test of Tom
Hiddleston dressed like Thor auditioning for
Thor.
But as we know he ended up going for Loki
he slimmed down and became one of the best
villains that marvels ever had, but think
that's why people want to play Lotta crazy
villains in the marvel universe Carnage, literally
being insane like he is actually certified
crazy most of the villains in the marvel universe
are normal people to go crazy, but the whole
idea behind the Carnage character is that
part of the venom sin be a which is already
up in a pretty evil thing by itself gets bonded
to a person who is legitimately insane like
venom bonds to Eddie Brock just as a big beef
again Spider-Man is just heightened some of
his more violent tendencies, but imagine the
venom Symbiote bonded to someone who was already
a really bad serial killer in a maximum security
prison, which as a little kid was my first
encounter with the character so just a start
with, comic book Carnage.
I'll explain the ultimate Spider-Man version
of Carnage to because that's kind of a blend
of a bunch of different storylines and arcs
from the Spider-Man comics the way back in
the early 90s like pretty close to when the
time Deadpool debuted Carnage debuted this
is the time in Marvel comics.
When they're getting super hard-core so course
you like to the craziest characters in their
history debuting, but Eddie Brock is currently
a prisoner in Rikers Island prison he does
not have the venom Symbiote he's been separated
for it.
That's why he's locked up otherwise he breakout
instantly if you had the sin be a it as the
Scipio begins to run free and eventually makes
its way to Rikers where Eddie Brock is his
cellmate Kletus Kasidy also gets bonded to
a piece of it and becomes the Carnage character
killing a guard escaping going on a rampage
so that was about a year between the time
Kletus Kasidy first appeared as like Eddie
Brock cellmate in Rikers Island prison and
when he actually took on the Carnage persona.
So the way they explain Carnage is that the
venom Symbiote out when it was trying to rescue
Eddie Brock inside Rikers so that it was pregnant
which is like a crazy idea but you have to
remember this is the early 90s.
So when they did it on the ultimate Spider-Man
cartoon the actually turned it into this Green
goblin plot where he makes a special version
of the venom Symbiote out and tried to inject
Peter Parker with it turning him into Carnage.
So TV Carnage has like a slightly more believable
origin story.
But, comic book Kletus Kasidy Carnage is just
a super deep cut.
So it's always fun to see what Marvel does
with the character so he's been around for
a long time but Carnage was just meant to
be like the Huber version of venom like Spider-Man
has a lot of big battles with the venom Symbiote
out.
It's very powerful, it's bonded to someone
who is mostly they're all up top but you have
to imagine like if the venom Symbiote out
bonded to someone who, just completely insane
the horrors that they would unleash so just
like the things that the Carnage Cynthia would
do were just so much freakier than venom,
but the powers of the Scipio are actually
relatively malleable like it really just depends
on the person that is bonded to, so venom
could do this stuff to it is that he's not
that crazy.
So originally in the comics Carnage debuts
and he's this villain the just so over-the-top
Spider-Man can't defeat him by himself so.
The twist as you would imagine is that he
needs the help of Eddie Brock venom to take
down this new sin be a because the only thing
the venom hates more than Spider-Man right
now is this new Symbiote out so they team
up to Carnage down and then go back to being
enemies.
So on the Spider-Man animated TV show there
actually two versions of the Carnage character
the first one was a variation on the venom
Symbiote out that Norman Osborne tried to
inject Peter Parker with you know for a brief
time he became Carnage in a couple seasons
later in season four.
They did a symbiosis August storyline.
It was kind of a blend of a couple different
Spider-Man arcs including maximum Carnage
and spider Island maximum Carnage was just
a storyline were Carnage a couple years after
he debuted in the comics broke out of an insane
asylum again recruited his own version of
the sinister six and went on like a mass killing
spree in the city that a bunch of heroes including
Spider-Man and venom had a team up to stop
them.
Spider Island was a storyline that involve
the antivenom helped cure the spider virus
that was turning people into like mutated
giant spiders, so they kind of combine those
arcs for the ultimate Spider-Man cartoon to
do their Symbiote storyline which is based
like a three-part story the of the Carnage
Symbiote of the debuts you need antivenom
to take them down antivenom is like a completely
separate idea, it's basically a mutated version
of the original venom Symbiote out that bonds
with Eddie Brock's white blood cells and becomes
a Symbiote capable of healing any disease.
So the he's the cure this giant spider virus
is turning everybody into giant man spiders.
So really like one of the biggest differences
between the Carnage Symbiote out in the venom
Symbiote out is that venom needs a host to
bond to in order to.
You know, take physical form the Carnage Symbiote
out does not need that they enter member is
the offspring of the venom Symbiote out so
it's a little bit different it's not like
an exact copy, but it just meant to be like
the freaky craziest possible version, you
could imagine of the venom Symbiote out so
they might choose to do spider virus or your
version of spider Island or of venom story
arc in the new movies that it'll take him
a long time to get to Carnage because you
kinda have to do the venom Symbiote outburst
and Sony was originally planning of venom
spinoff Spider-Man movie before they made
the deal with Marvel so that's all kind of
up in the air now like they were going to
make a sinister six movie.
But this was during Andrew Garfield era so
they're still doing that stuff, but it's kind
of been back burner because of the new Spider-Man
Homecoming trilogy.
So what I think they'll probably do is slowly
weave in the idea of venom in the Spider-Man
movies of eventually and then just kind of
try and do it off as a separate thing.
It just depends on what the tone of the Spider-Man
movies are gonna be because is going to be
in high school for the duration of his new
trilogy.
I really think that venom Carnage is better
left for like super early phase 5 if it's
gonna be a Marvel joint but it almost seems
like it would be easier for them if they were
to do what they were originally planning on
doing it just to venom is a separate thing
and then introduce Carnage during that story
line because Carnage is really a twist on
a venom idea.
So those two characters just go hand-in-hand
and I just love the idea that there's somebody
that venom hates more than Peter Parker, but
the big twist of the Spider-Man Homecoming
movie this first movie is that all these kids
are in high school and you have characters
that will eventually become hobgoblin you
have flash Thompson, who himself became venom
space night eventually like one of the host
of the venom Symbiote owed and they all just
seem like super buddies you just know that
something terrible has to happen between them
eventually.
Let me know in the comments how do you think
that Sony and Marvel would choose to do the
venom and Carnage characters.
Do you think that will ever see them in the
main Marvel films that they're making or do
you think that they'll try to just do spinoff
movies by themselves.
So there couple other Marvel videos that I
want to do this weekend there teasing a brand-new
in human on agents of shield like a new mystery
inhumans.
I'll probably do a video for that and Kevin
Feige just confirmed the Captain Marvel is
going to be the most powerful character that
they've ever done like we've seen Odin we've
seen Dormammu Thanos.
So there are also other superpowerful characters
but I think he was talking mostly about heroes
there can be getting their own solo spinoff
movies so that Captain Marvel video will probably
be next.
So I'll post that in a little while while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for that Funny Spider-Man Tom Holland
video and you can click here for the latest
Huge Trailer for the Flash 4 night crossover,
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!